Sie haben alle nichts Besseres zu tun.
Bitte schön.
Okay.
Okay, so fangen wir ja.
Ja.
Ja, hallo, guten Tag.
Ich bin als Assistentat dieser Staatsanthetik.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch durchführen.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht bestanden haben, bitte, saluen Sie mir Bescheid.
Ja, sprechen Sie bitte ein bisschen langsamer.
Ja, natürlich.
Okay.
Ja, dann kann ich Sie besser verstehen.
So, Sonners, ich möchte einfach fragen,
wie Sie Ihre persönlichen Daten fragen.
Ja.
Wie, dann werden wir über Ihre aktuelle Bescheid werden schüchtern.
Alles klar.
Aber wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Linus Müller.
Ich bin ein Mann.
Okay.
Herr Müller, können Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname bestabieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist Linus L-I-N-U-S.
Genau, und Nachname bitte.
Müller, M-U-Umlaut, Double L-E-R.
Genau, okay, danke schön.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Waren Sie genau geboren, Herr Müller?
Ich bin 27 Jahre, bin geboren am 27.04.1996.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin nicht so groß, ich bin 178.
Ein bisschen groß, ja.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich wiege zu 72 kg.
72 kg, okay.
So, Herr Müller, was führt die Suche?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe solche ganz, ganz heftigen Schmerzen.
Und zwar hier auf der linken Seite im Bauch.
Ich bin nämlich, ja, das ist eine dumme Geschichte.
Ich bin Skateboard gefahren.
Und dann bin ich hingefallen und bin gegen einen Zaun geprahlt.
Und dann hatte ich ganz starke Schmerzen,
aber die haben sich dann eigentlich so ein bisschen verbessert
und dann bin ich auch erstmal nach Hause gegangen
und war eigentlich, ja, dann wurde es ein bisschen besser.
Und waren genau, können Sie bitte mir sagen?
Das war heute Vormittag.
Vormittag, aha, okay.
Und dann habe ich mich halt zu Hause hingelegt
und dann hatte ich das Gefühl, die Schmerzen werden besser.
Und ich habe dann gedacht, das ist draußen so warm
und wenn das so weh tut, wenn ich mir da etwas,
was ich die Muskeln geprellt habe oder so, wenn da ein Blutergust kommt,
dann kühle ich das mal ein bisschen, habe ich ein bisschen gekühlt
und ich hatte das Gefühl, ja, wird besser.
Und jetzt sind mir einmal die Schmerzen ganz schlimm geworden.
Ja.
Und dann hat mich, also, ja, dann hat mich ein Nachbar hierher gebracht
und ich konnte das nicht mehr aushalten.
Genau, okay, Herr Müller, können Sie bitte mir sagen,
wo ist die Schmerzen?
Wo ist, genau.
Der Schmerz?
Der linken Bauch, Ober- oder unten?
Oben im Bauch.
Also oberhalb vom Bauchnabel, auf der linken Seite.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
So, können Sie bitte, bitte, diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie herrsichernd, dumpf oder stetschend
oder...
Wie kann ich die beschreiben?
Also, ich würde sagen, dumpf, Sie, ihr habt so einen Druckschmerz
und, ja, also ich habe auch das Gefühl,
dass es mir wirklich ganz schlecht geht, ja.
Ich mein Herz klopft ganz doll und puh, ja.
Haben Sie Herz gelupft, nicht?
Bitte?
Haben Sie Herz klopft, ne?
Ja.
Okay, was ist mit Atemnot?
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Luft bekomme ich wohl, aber ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl,
dass es mir jetzt sehr, sehr schlecht geht.
Okay, können Sie bitte beschreiben?
Können Sie bitte mir sagen,
wie stark ist die Schmerzen in einer Schmerzskala?
Nur bis zehn, wobei nur keine Schmerzen
und zehn sehr stark Schmerzen.
Sie sind bei acht bis neun, würde ich sagen.
Also, das ist für mich kaum auszuhalten.
Das sind sehr starke Schmerzen.
Ja, ich bin mir so leid.
Herr Müller, können Sie bitte am Ende unserer Gespräche aufhalten, bitte.
Ja, muss ich ja wohl, ja.
Wenn es schnell geht, ja.
Mir ist wirklich, ich habe Angst und puh,
und mir ist wirklich ganz schlecht.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Also, Frau Herr Müller, können Sie bitte mir sagen,
Sie haben hingefallen, richtig?
Sie sind hingefallen.
Ich bin hingefallen, ja.
Ich bin mit einem Skateboard gefahren,
und da hat man ja schon ordentlich Geschwindigkeit drauf.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben sich verletzt, haben sich Verletzungen bemerkt,
im...
Also, die linken Rafa-Seite,
habe ich blaue Flecken, ja.
Blaue Flecken, okay.
Okay, wo genau ist diese blaue Flecken?
Ich glaube, so an der Hüfte sind welche am oberen Schenkel.
Und an der Hüfte.
Bitte?
Okay.
Also, am oberen Schenkel,
und an der Hüfte,
und eben auch so im Bauchbereich.
Auch im Bauchbereich.
Ober, links.
Ja, alles auf der linken Seite.
Ja, okay, okay.
Alle sind links.
Okay, jetzt, momentan, Sie haben Bauchschmerzen, richtig?
Auch haben Sie...
Ich habe sehr, sehr schlimme Bauchschmerzen.
Zwischendurch waren die besser,
und dachte ich, alles ist gut.
Aber jetzt sind die Schmerzen wirklich ganz, ganz heftig.
Okay, ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Schwindelig ist mir eigentlich nicht, nein.
Okay.
So ist Ihnen übel.
Mir ist eigentlich schlecht vor Schmerzen und vor Angst auch.
Warum haben Sie Angst?
Ja, weil es so Schmerz hat, weil ich mich so schlecht fühle.
Ja, ich weiß ja, okay, bitte machen Sie keine Angst.
Sie haben sehr gut Entscheidungen getroffen bei uns gekommen.
Ich werde mich mit Sie kümmern.
Um Sie kümmern.
Ich werde mich um Sie kümmern, Frau Heimüller.
Haben Sie sich übergeben?
Kein Mirller?
Nein, nein.
Okay, keine.
Okay, so.
Haben Sie Husten?
Husten? Nein, ich habe Bauchschmerzen.
Ich habe mich verletzt.
Ich habe heftige Bauchschmerzen.
Genau, ich verstehe.
Jetzt haben Sie Kribbelgefühle oder Taubheitgefühle?
Nein, aber als Gefühl habe ich nichts.
Würde ich jetzt nicht, nein.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich Fieber habe.
Okay, Schüttelfrost, Kalschweiß oder?
Ja, so ein bisschen Kalschweiß, ich bin schon,
ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich so Kalschweiß habe.
Okay, seid ihr warm?
Ja, direkt danach, nach dem Unfall.
Okay.
Haben Sie andere Beschwerden?
Von dem ich wissen soll, Herr Müller?
Ich weiß nicht, was ich noch beschreiben soll.
Mir geht es einfach schlecht.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlisten oder mit Stuhlgang?
Normalerweise nicht, ich bin 27 Jahre alt.
Da habe ich ja hoffentlich nichts in der Richtung.
Aber ob jetzt irgendwas ist, ich bin noch nicht so oft auf der Toilette gewesen.
Aber das hat natürlich weh getan.
Klar, wenn ich versucht habe zu drücken, aber sonst,
das war das alles normal.
Okay, ich verstehe, das ist gut.
Herr Müller, haben Sie etwas probiert um Schmerzen solider?
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe das kühlt.
Okay, nur Bauchbereich oder auch im Schenkelbereich?
Nein, ich habe da, wo die blauen Flecken waren,
habe ich halt ein bisschen gekühlt.
Und ich hatte dann eben das Gefühl,
das hinlegen zu Hause, dass das erst mal geholfen hat,
dass es ein bisschen besser wurde.
Und mit allem wurden die Schmerzen aber ganz schlimm.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe.
Wie Sie merken, sind Sie immer da oder gehen Sie wieder zurück?
Jetzt sind Sie immer da.
Seit Vormittag nach dem Unfall?
Da waren Sie erst ganz stark, dann haben Sie sich verbessert
und plötzlich wurden Sie wieder schlechter.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Ja, okay, jetzt haben Sie geschwollene Bauch oder Bein?
Ein bisschen Schwellung ist da natürlich von den blauen Flecken, ja.
Okay, so haben Sie Bewegungsstörungen, können Sie gut bewegen?
Nein, ich habe wahnsinnige Schmerzen, ich kann mich nicht bewegen, nein.
Alles klar, okay, okay.
Haben Sie Rötung in irgendwo, außer diese blauen Flecken?
Rötung, Wärmung?
Ja, das ist so zwischen rot und blau.
Da sind so ein paar rote Stellen, wo ich halt draufgefallen bin.
Okay, haben Sie Wärmung bemerkt?
Was habe ich gemerkt?
Heizergefühl, Wärmung in irgendwo.
Ach Hitze, Hitzegefühl, Wärmelgefühl, ja, ja, so ein bisschen da, wo diese Schwellungen sind.
Deswegen habe ich das gekühlt.
Ja, okay.
So, Frau Hermüler, okay, so haben Sie andere Beschwerden-Pilaz, oder?
Nein, aber die reichen mir völlig, die Beschwerden, die ich habe.
Ja, okay, ja, alles klar, ich verstehe.
Als vor der Trankung, Herr Müller, haben Sie irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Ja, also ich habe Neurodermitis, schon als Kind.
Da hatte ich das so hinter den Ohren und an den Armen und in den Kniekehlen.
Welche Knie? Welche Salz?
Auch beiden Salz.
Auf dem Knie, beiden Salz, okay.
Also, die Kind war richtig?
Ja, also ich habe seit der Kindheit.
Okay, seit Kindheit.
Aber ich habe das immer noch.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Wie alt waren Sie?
Ich glaube, als ich so 5, 6 war, hat es angefangen.
6, ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Okay, haben Sie andere Erkrankungen auch?
Ja, ich hatte jetzt in den letzten Jahren ziemlich viel Stress
und da habe ich ein bisschen Migräne mal bekommen.
Also da habe ich so 2-3 Mal im Monat, habe ich so Migräne-Attacken.
Ja, ich verstehe, ich stelle mir das so leid.
Okay, waren Sie schon bei einem Haushalt?
Ja, natürlich, da bin ich in Behandlung, ja.
Ja, sehr gut.
Also, welche Medikamente nehmen Sie oder nehmen Sie ganz welche Medikamente ein?
Begen, misst ich, was ab und zu?
Bitte?
Nehmen Sie ganz welche Medikamente?
Ja, also wenn ich diese Kopfschmerzen habe, dann habe ich halt immer Aspirin dabei.
Okay, wie viele Medikamente?
Und wie viele mal?
Oder bei Bedarf?
Ja, ich nehme das so, glaube ich, 500.
Wenn eine nicht hilft, muss ich noch eine nehmen.
Ja, okay.
Und für die Neurodermitis habe ich halt, wenn das schlimm wird,
so eine Salbe, die ich da drauf tun kann.
Ich glaube, das ist so eine Cortisonsalpe.
Cortisonsalpe, okay, das ist auch bei Bedarf, richtig?
Ja, die nehme ich nur, wenn das gerade wieder unangenehm ist, ja.
Okay, so andere Medikamente auch oder nur das?
Nee, das mehr nehme ich nicht.
Herr Müller, würden Sie sich schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich hatte, ich hatte, ja, ich bin so ein Unfallheld.
Ich hatte ein Bruch am linken Oberarm und auch noch eine Platzwunde am Kopf.
Und da bin ich auch mit dem Fahrrad damals gestürzt.
Und das musste operiert werden, also der Armbruch.
Okay, so wann war das?
Vor fünf Jahren war das.
Vor fünf Jahren, okay.
In welcher Operation wurde durchgeführt, wissen Sie,
vielleicht Plättin, 8000 oder so?
Man hat da, man hat da eine Platte reingesetzt und schrauben
und die mussten dann hinterher auch wieder rausgemacht werden.
Okay, wann wieder rausgemacht, diese Plättin?
Ja.
Ja, wann genau?
Ich habe es vielleicht seit einem Jahr.
Oder anderthalb Jahren oder so.
Okay, so diese Oberarmbruch,
haben Sie irgendeine Operation auch gehabt?
War andere Operationen nicht?
Ja, okay.
Okay, so ist bei Ihnen irgendeine Verschrift Allergien bekannt, Herr Müller?
Was ist?
Ist bei Ihnen irgendeine Verschrift Allergien bekannt?
Ja, ich vertrag kein Amoxicillin.
Okay, Amoxicillin, okay.
Wie äußert sich diese Allergien?
Da kriege ich so einen Ausschlag.
Okay, okay, nur das?
Oder haben Sie andere Anreignung, Petri Lichlikaitin oder so?
Ja, also eigentlich, das ist das einzige.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Frau Müller, rauchen Sie?
Herr Müller.
Entschuldigung, nicht zu mir so leicht.
Herr Müller, rauchen Sie?
Ja, also ich habe lange Zeit geraucht,
aber eigentlich seit vier Jahren rauch ich nicht mehr.
Sehr gut entscheidet.
Also ein paar Jahre habe ich aber nicht nie doll geraucht.
Ja, wie viel haben Sie geraucht und für welche seid ihr?
Das war vielleicht so über fünf, sechs Jahre,
da habe ich aber auch nur so ein halbes Päckchen am Tag geraucht.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Okay, Sie haben eine sehr gute Entscheidung getroffen.
Ja, ist zwar viel Geld, ja.
Ja, das ist auch wichtig.
Trinken Sie alles hoch, Herr Müller?
Ja, eigentlich trinke ich so ziemlich regelmäßig jeden Abend Glas Wein.
Jedem Ein Glas Wein.
Okay, haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen, Herr Müller?
Das ist nur eine standardmäßige Frage.
Drogen, da habe ich überhaupt gar keine Erfahrung.
Ja, okay, wunderbar.
Was machen Sie, Herr Müller?
Ich arbeite bei der Deutschen Bahn.
Ich bin der Zuggegleiter.
Okay, sehr gut.
Haben Sie sich stressig gedreht bei der Arbeit?
Ja, weiß Gott, da hat man mehr als Stress, ja.
Ja, ja, ich verstehe.
Die Züge sind immer zu spät und wir sind immer die Dummen.
Die Leute beschweren sich bei uns.
Ja, okay.
So, ziehen Sie nachher.
Was haben Sie eine feste Beziehung?
Ja, ich bin geschieden und ich habe aber eine neue Partnerin.
Neue Partnerin?
Partnerin?
Okay, so haben die Kinder.
Ja, wir haben eine Tochter.
Ist sie gesund?
Die Tochter ist gesund, ja, die liebt bei meiner Ex-Frau.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ist bei ihrer Familie irgendetwas erkrankt mit dem Bekannt?
Vater, Mama, Geschwister oder Opa, Oma?
War mein Zwillingsbruder, der hat Asthma, das weiß ich.
Und mein Vater, der hatte mal eine schlimme Krebserkrankung.
Was für Krebs, wie Sie es sehen?
Ja, im Dickdarm.
Und da ist er mit Chemotherapie behandelt worden.
Okay, mit welchem Lebensjahr?
Ja, das war noch nicht so lange her.
Da war er Mitte 50.
Mitte 50?
Wie?
55 können wir sagen?
Ja, ja, irgendwie so, 55, 56.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Hat irgendetwas andere Erkrankungen gehabt?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Was ist mit Ihrer Mutter?
Die hat ein bisschen Hüftprobleme, die humpelt ein bisschen.
Sie hat gesagt, dass sie irgendwann mal eine neue künstliche Hüfte kriegt,
aber noch humpelt sie in der Gegend rum.
Sie wurde operiert, richtig?
Nein, sie wurde noch nicht operiert.
Sie soll eine künstliche Hüfte bekommen, oder vielleicht auch zwei.
Aber im Augenblick wartet sie noch.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Hat sie irgendetwas andere Erkrankungen gehabt?
Oder nur diese Hüftprobleme?
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
So, Herr Müller, ich bin fertig mit meiner Frage,
und haben Sie Frage nach mir?
Ja, was können wir jetzt gegen diese Schmerzen machen?
Und mir geht es wirklich so unendlich schlecht.
Ich fühle mich wirklich ganz klar.
Natürlich, natürlich.
Ich möchte so nach der Körperlehrung untersuchen,
danach ein paar Untersuchungen dürfen.
Wie Bauchustraschaft und Torax.
Ich nehme meinen Torax Bauch und Bein und Hüfte.
Ich nehme Ihnen Blut ab.
Wenn wir mehr Untersuchungen brauchen,
werden wir Ihnen bescheiden.
Okay, alles klar.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen andere Fragen?
Ja, haben Sie sich in den letzten fünf Jahren gegen Tetanus geimpft?
Ah, ja, ich bin gegen Tetanus geimpft.
Haben Sie zum Unfall seit Punkt einen Helm getragen?
Ja, genau, er hat einen Helm getragen.
Und am Kopf hat er sich nichts getan.
Okay, danke.
Ah, ja, ich habe gesagt, meine Nachbarin hat mich gebracht.
Wahrscheinlich ist eigentlich, dass er mit einem Notarztwagen gekommen ist,
wenn ich das so angucke.
Wann hatten Sie das letzte Mal auswählen eingenommen?
Oh, das ist eine gute Frage.
Das ist schon länger her, jetzt nicht die letzten Tage.
Okay, danke schön.
Und Sie lässt einmal etwas gegessen?
Oh, auch eine gute Frage.
Ja, zum Frühstück habe ich zuletzt etwas gegessen.
Unsere Kollegen hat gefragt, aber ich möchte wieder ausführliche Fragen stellen.
Seit Beginn hat es einen Stuhlgang oder Gehenwinde ab?
Das ist mir nicht, also ich habe da wohl einmal Stuhlgang gehabt,
aber das war unauffällig.
Und Irin?
Welche Frage?
Ja, du, Wasser lassen musste ich auch und das war auch unauffällig.
Danke schön.
Ne, so arbeiten wir denn nicht mehr danach.
Sind Sie nach dem Unfall unmächtig geworden?
Nein, ich meine, ich war die ganze Zeit bei mir.
Haben Sie aktuell offene Ställe?
Ja, vielleicht so leichte Schürfhunden, das müssen wir uns gleich mal angucken.
Abschürfen?
Aber, dass er jetzt eine große Wunde war, die geblutet hat, das war nicht nein.
Und wie war Ihr Schwindigkeit?
Bitte was?
Wie war Ihr Schwindigkeit?
Geschwindigkeit.
Wie schnell ist man mit so einem Skateboard?
Ich denke, man fährt vielleicht schon so 25, 30 Stundenkilometer.
Vielleicht 20, ja so schnell fährt man vielleicht.
20, 25, denke ich, keine Ahnung, wie schnell man fährt.
Und haben Sie vor dem Unfall etwas Ungewinnes bemerkt,
zum Beispiel Schwarz vor den Augen?
Nein, also mir ging es gut.
Ich habe nur diesen blöden Zaun, da diese Schwelle nicht gesehen
und bin gegen den Zaun geknallt.
Aktuell haben Sie Nackenstärkigkeit?
Nackenstärkigkeit, nein.
Und Lehmung oder Kraftlosigkeit in der Exzellenität?
Nein.
Danke.
Okay, danke schön.
Frau Gehild, ich möchte eine Kurse so schnell
vorstellen und dann eine Gönnl vorstellen.
Wenn Sie in Ordnung sind.
Noch mal, wen möchten Sie vorstellen?
Ich möchte zuerst den Patienten vorstellen, ja,
und dann aber ganz kurz.
Ja, okay.
Er hat sich bei uns wegen heute Morgen
nach dem Unfall aufgetretenen,
bestehend der Progrediente Bauchsmärz in Lincoln, Oberland,
Quadranten vorgelegt hat.
Außerdem beschrieben er die Schmerzen als Dumpf und Druckkund.
Außerdem hat er seine Lincoln-Seite,
manchmal eskoriation und seine Lincoln-Oberflanken,
eine Hematom.
Die Schmerz-Intensität geht auf der Ennärsie mit 8 bis 9 Angegeben,
die ist in der Folge,
da sind sie auf die Angegeben.
Die Schmerz-Intensität geht auf die Ennärsie mit 8 bis 9 Angegeben,
die ist in der Folge,
die Schmerz-Intensität geht auf die Angegeben.
Ja, alles.
Okay.
Grünen.
Ja, okay.
Hallo.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin gesehen
und untergesucht.
Untergesucht, ja.
Nichts trennbares Verb.
Nicht untersucht, untersucht.
Nein, untersuchen ist ein nicht trennbares Verb.
Ja.
Also sagen wir, ich habe ihn untersucht.
Ich habe ihn, ich habe den Patientin untersucht.
Untersucht, oder einem Nestgeschipel durchgeführt.
Untersucht.
Können wir sagen, aufgenommen?
Was bedeutet?
Also ich habe einen neuen Patientin gesehen.
Erstmal, untersuchen kommt ja nachher erst.
Ja.
Ja?
Okay.
Ich habe einen neuen Patientin gesehen.
Oder aufgenommen, wie auch immer.
Ja.
Okay.
Ich habe ihn aufgenommen.
Ja.
27 jähriger Pat librarians.
Geborgen am,
Geborgen am
27 delayed 16 14 19.
98?
96.
96?
4, Topre 47?
Ja.
Ja, okay. Ich habe Probleme mit 6 und 8.
Ja, 1,78 m groß, 2,78 m groß.
78, ja, okay.
2,70 kg schwer.
Ja?
Er wurde bei ihrer Nachbarin bei uns gebracht.
Von seiner Nachbarin.
Er wurde von seiner Nachbarin zu uns gebracht.
Er wurde von seiner Nachbarin von uns gebracht.
Von wem zu wem zu uns gebracht.
Ja, von ihrer Nachbarin.
Von seiner Nachbarin zu uns gebracht.
Er ist ein Mann, also ist es seine Nachbarin zu uns gebracht.
Von uns gebracht, okay.
Zu uns gebracht.
Ja, nach einem...
Unfall.
Er ist hingepallen wegen des Skateboards.
Er selber gefahren oder ist er angerempt worden?
Er ist hingepallen. Entschuldigung, ich habe nicht verstanden.
Ist er selber das Skateboard gefahren
oder ist er von einem Skateboard angefahren worden?
Selber, ja.
Ja, er stand selber drauf.
Ja, ich spiel drauf.
Ja, der Unfall hat heute Mittag passiert.
Ist passiert, ja?
Ist passiert, ja.
Und der Patient habe dumpfe, drückende Oberbauchschmerzen links.
Ich habe auch Herzkluffe.
Warum ist er nicht gleich gekommen?
Nach dem Unfall, die beschwerden, wurden besser geworden.
Haben besser geworden.
Sind besser geworden, ja.
Sind besser geworden.
Aber im Verlauf der Zeit haben sie sich verschlechtert.
Ah, ja, okay.
Ja, deswegen hat er zu uns gekommen.
Von der Nachbarin zu uns gekommen.
Momentan habe er Empfindlichkeit in Oberbauch links.
Und fliegt links seit ganz der Körper blauen Flecken.
Wie nennen wir die?
Bräu, Bräu.
Hämatome.
Ja, Hämatome, ja.
Natürlich Hämatome.
Er hat momentan Hämatome im linkseitigen Körper brach.
Bereit brach.
Ja, die Schmerzen sind, ja, ich habe schon gesagt,
ich habe schon gesagt, sich in Parler
und derzeit verschlechtert.
Ja, Schmerzkala.
Ja, die Schmerzen, Schmerzintensität
liegen bei 8 bis 9 von 10 auf der Schmerzkala.
Mhm.
Gut, haben Sie den Patienten sofort Vitalparameter untersucht?
Ja, ich muss Vitalparameter untersuchen
und Körperliontersuchungen durchführen.
Mhm, aber Sie haben es noch nicht gemacht?
Ich habe gemacht, ja, natürlich.
Ich habe mit Vitalparameter untersucht
und untersucht, untersucht, untersucht.
Untersucht?
Ja, untersucht und Vitalparameter angemessen.
Ja, ich habe eine Ultraschein durchgeführt.
Mhm.
Ja, aber in diesem Fall, wenn wir sagen, ich habe gemacht,
es wird nicht verdachtdiagnose sein, es wird Diagnose sein.
Ja, aber wenn ein Patient mit diesem Bestand kommt,
ja, so nach ich muss, so nach ich muss,
Körperliontersuchungen und Blutentnahme machen Labor,
ja, ja, und einfach mal gucken, ob der überhaupt noch
ja, Körperliontersuchungen, Vitalparameter,
der Patient müsste eigentlich in Schockraum
oder Notfallraum, ja, oder ob der Patient
müsste eigentlich in Schockraum oder Notfallraum
oder auf die Intensivstation.
Genau, Stationaraufnahme, ja.
Ja, Stationaraufnahme, ja.
Also, das würde ich sagen, ist das Hauptproblem,
dass Sie praktisch weitergemacht haben
mit den Fragen, ohne zu sagen, wir unterbrechen jetzt.
Ich muss Sie jetzt erst körperlich untersuchen.
Wir überprüfen jetzt erst mal eine Überprüfung
der Vitalparameter und Monitoring und alles andere.
Frage ich dann hinterher.
Ja, genau, okay, ja, danke schön.
Das denke ich mal, wäre in so einem Fall wichtig.
Aber na gut, also, wir tun jetzt mal so,
als hätten Sie es nicht gemacht
und Sie erzählen weiter, was Sie über den Patienten
rausgefunden haben und was Sie daraus schließen, ja?
Ja, natürlich, mein, ja, es kann,
wir können sagen Ihnen Blutung sein.
Deswegen möchte ich so als Intensivstation aufgenommen.
Ja, und Monitor, Monitor,
über Woche ist sehr wichtig.
Genau.
Ich mache den Patienten 24 Stunden immer.
Und ja.
Was hat der Patient, was hat er noch für Beschwerden geschildert
oder wie haben Sie weiter gefragt?
Ich will Sie jetzt nicht ganz auf den Konzept bringen.
Ja, Schwellung und Hämatomen, Hitze gefühlt.
Ja, gibt es bei den Patienten vorhanden?
Lokale Hitze gefühlt, oder Generalität gefühlt?
Generell.
Ich denke, lokale Hitze gefühlt.
Nur da, wo die Schwellung sind, hat er gesagt.
Ja, ich finde es nicht heiß.
Lokale.
Ja, ja, ja, lokale, natürlich, ja,
diese linken Seite, die Hitze gefühlt.
Aha, ja, das noch kann man sagen.
Wie eine amnestische Ordnungs-
Ja, weiter, weiter, die ganzen Fragen, die Sie gestellt haben.
Sie haben ja eine Menge los.
Ja, okay.
Soll ich weiter machen mit den Patienten?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, okay.
Vorher kranken bei den Patienten nur damit,
nur damit es bekannt.
Hinter Ohrenarm,
hinter Ohrenarm und Knie, beidseitig.
Also hinter den Ohren und an den Armen
und in die Knie kehren beidseitig, okay?
Und seit wann hat er das?
Seit Kindheit.
Seit Kindheit, genau.
Seit 5 oder 6 Jahren war.
Ja, und stressbedingte Migraine.
Er hat berichtet, die Migräne, diese Migräne kommt,
kommt als Ertagen, Migräne beschwerden, kommt als Ertagen,
2, 3 Mal pro Monat.
Und der Patient nehme dagegen Kopfschmerzen ausbringt.
Ich und das Milikam bei Bedarf bis 1 oder 2 Tableten
und gegen Neurodermitis, Zalbe, Cortisolzalbe bei Bedarf,
unklare Todes.
Ja, Operationen vor Operationen, linke Oberarm,
Bruch, Fraktur, nach dem Paratunfall vor 5 Jahren.
Ja, ja, Bruch, Fraktur, die Fraktur wurde mit Blätten behandelt,
Präzit Osteosynthese bei den Patienten durchgeführt.
Ja, und nachdem 1,5 Jahre, oder Jahre, 13 Jahre, 13, Entfernung.
wurde mit Hallen fern, genau.
Und Allergie bei den Patienten,
die Sessilien Allergie, am offiziellen Allergie bekommt,
diese Allergie ausser sich durch, durch Exanten
und Noxen Allergie steht.
Der Patient, der Patient ist nicht rauchig momentan,
aber früher, halbe Packung, täglich halbe Packung
für bis 6 Jahre gerafft.
Mhm.
Allkohlkonsum.
Das war noch auf der nicht mehr?
Seit 4 Jahren, auch nicht mehr.
Ja, Alkoholkonsum geläse Wein täglich.
Ein Glas Wein täglich, ne?
Ja, ein Glas Wein täglich.
Keine Kontakte mit Drogen.
Nein, Kontakte.
Sozialanämpfestisch, Arbeit als Suchbegleiter
beim Deutschen Bahn.
Ja, stressig.
Das ist stressig, ja, kann man sich vorstellen.
Ja, er ist sehr geschehen, lebe mit ihrer Partnerin,
mit seiner Partnerin.
Mit seiner Partnerin, was habe ich gesagt?
Mit ihrer Partnerin.
Mit seiner Partnerin, ja.
Ich habe eine Tochter, sie ist ganz gesund,
die Tochter lebe mit ihrer Mutter.
Familienanämpfestisch, ja, Vater,
mit einem Krebs Kolonkartino.
Kolonkartino?
Ja, Chemotherapie, mit Chemotherapie behandelt,
Chemotherapie behandelt.
Ja, hat diese Krebs mit 56 Lebensjahr gehabt.
Mutter, ja, habe Probleme mit Hüftproblemen,
ich muss der Patientin sagen,
sie muss operiert behandeln.
Muss operativ behandelt werden, ja.
Wie nennen wir das?
Tip total endoprotez.
Genau.
Genau, wie heißt die Erkrankung?
Konatros.
Koksatrosin, Hüfte, nicht nie.
Ja, ja, ich schuldigung natürlich.
Der Patient habe ein Bruder,
er leide anassen.
Okay, gut.
Was ist denn jetzt ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Ja, innenblutung, innenorganenblutung.
Was ist das für eine Struktur?
Ja, mit Milchstruktur.
Was spricht denn dafür?
Blaue Flecken, Hämmerton.
Ja, aber was spricht noch dafür?
Was hat der geschildert, sehr dezidiert?
Starkenschmerzen.
Ja, die starken Schmerzen, ja.
Übelkeit.
Ja, das spricht noch für die Milchstruktur.
Er hat etwas spezielles geschildert, er hat etwas spezielles geschildert.
Er hat gesagt, die Schmerzen waren erst ganz schlimm
und dann sind sie besser geworden.
Er dachte er schon, auch so schlimm wird es nicht.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Und dann kamen sie wieder.
Ja, in einem Intervall, wenn es für mich trifft, es nicht.
Wenn es für mich sind Schmerzen, die immer wieder kommen.
Ja, aber er hatte starke Schmerzen, die sich dann gemäßigt haben
und danach hat er mit einmal plötzlich wieder starke Schmerzen gehabt.
So, und so, das, wie kommt das?
Intervallisch kaltest du?
Ja, wie kommt das?
Ja, was? Wieso spricht das für eine Milztruktur?
Blödschlich, abgetretene.
Die zweizeitige Milztruktur.
Ja, erst...
Erst gibt es das Trauma im Organ und nachher durch die Blutung und die Schwellung
sprengt die Kapseln.
Und dann werden die Schmerzen ganz schlimm.
Ja?
Ja, kalt Schweiß auch.
Ja, er ist auch kalt Schweißig und er hat Todesangst.
Ja?
Dieser Patient hat eine massive innere Blutung
und dem ist seine Milzkapsel geknallt.
Ja.
Ja, genau.
Das ist eben typisch diese zwei Zeiten.
Erst das Trauma, was die Organschädigung macht,
dann die Blutung innen und danach, weil es eben gut durchblutet ist,
und danach die Sprengung der Kapsel
und dann die massiven Schmerzen und die massive Befundverschlechterung.
Genau, ja, genau.
Also, deswegen wahrscheinlich Milztruktur.
So, was könnte er denn noch haben oder zusätzlich haben?
Meinen Sie differential diagnostisch?
Ja, differential diagnostisch oder auch zusätzlich.
Mhm, okay, zusätzlich, okay.
Kann, ja, das ist für mich...
Was könnte er sich denn gebrochen haben?
Aha, ja, Muskel, wegen muskelverletzungen.
Rapto miolis?
Nein.
Wegen muskelverletzungen.
Nein, rapto miolis, kann ich so...
Ich meine, ich meine was anderes.
Was könnte passieren?
Er hat sich praktisch den linken Oberbauch angestoßen, stark.
Aha, okay, ja, ja, ja, kann natürlich nierenverletzungen sein.
Sie meinen...
Ich meine noch eine Rippenfraktur.
Aha, natürlich.
Das könnte sein, dass er praktisch den...
Aber keine Luftnote deswegen...
Stimmt, hat er gesagt, ja.
Aber er hat natürlich gesagt, dass ihm das alles wehtut,
auch beim Atmen, ne?
Weil er eben diese wahnsinnigen Bauchschmerzen hat.
Gut, also...
Das könnte auch noch sein vom Unfallhergang her.
Und ansonsten kann jedes Organ im Bauch natürlich verletzt sein.
Na? Gut.
Okay, ja, dann was machen Sie diagnostisch mit Patienten?
Diagnostisch, Körperleutersuchung,
Blutentenome...
Ach, sind Sie dabei, besonders?
Zunars Intensivstationäraufnahme.
Und danach eine Klage.
Mhm. Und das kriegt er auch gleich?
Was kriegt der gleich?
Was meinen Sie?
Na, ich denke, man legt vielleicht schon mal zwei Zugänge.
Natürlich, ja, ja, ja, das ist traumatisch.
Ja, zwei Zugänge, ja, wenn wir suchen.
Auf jeder Seite einen...
Ja, plusikalt, ja.
Elektrolyz, Elektrolyzmessung,
Elektrolyz und danach die gegebenen Krassen.
Elektrolyzgabe, ja.
Ja, ja.
Warum durchschariert?
Genau.
Und was erwarten Sie,
was erwarten Sie, wenn Sie den Patienten untersuchen,
körperlich?
Ja, zunars Instektion.
Ja, Hematomen,
ja, vielleicht...
Fraktur, wir können es sehen.
Ja, aber ist der zum Beispiel rosig
oder ist der eher blass?
Äh, rosig.
Ja, ja, ist der wegen Blutung, kann blass sein.
Ja, genau.
So, dann wird er wahrscheinlich, er sagt ja selber,
er hat Herzrasen.
Ja, genau.
Ja, dann kann Schock durchführen.
Ja, also er hat auf alle Fälle den Tariq-AD, ja.
Ja.
Der hat also einen schnellen Puls.
Ja, die Parameter sind sehr wichtig, ja.
Ja, so, und dann, das könnte noch sein,
dass man das allein schon sieht,
wenn Sie den angucken.
Äh, es kann, der muss zwar nicht verloren sein,
oder Kolobie, das kann Ihnen passieren,
dass der irgendwo die Füsse fällt, ja.
Ja, aber es kann auch sein,
dass man schon eine Schwellung am Bauch sieht, ne?
Ja, das ist ja für mich.
Dass man sieht, dass der Umfang mehr wird, ne?
Mhm.
Ja, also dass der unsymmetrisch, ne, der Bauchumfang ist.
Gut, und natürlich wird der Schmerzen haben.
Gut, Sie machen dann Ihre Ultraschalluntersuchung.
Und ja, da sehen Sie ja wahrscheinlich das Elend schon.
Ja, ja, ich sehe das.
Wenn Sie Ultraschallkopf draufhalten,
was sehen Sie dann wahrscheinlich?
Äh, ja, wir können mit einer größeren Milch sehen.
Und freie Flüssigkeit wahrscheinlich, ne?
Freie. Ja, freie Flüssigkeit in den Bauch.
Ja, gut.
Ja.
Gut, was machen Sie labortechnisch, ganz dringend?
Ja, Blutbild, Entschwungeparameter, Herz, Entschwungemittel,
Elektronik.
Und?
Leberwerte, Renalwerte,
wie können wir Milch beurteilen, wie mit Labor?
Ja, und was würden Sie vorsichtshalber auch schon mal machen?
Äh, ja, selber machen.
Sie meinen, sie als Labor oder Billgebande fangen?
Ja, als Labor.
Ja, ja, Blutbild, das ist Hemoglobinwerte.
Ja, aber Sie vermuten ja,
dass der eine innere Blutung hat, wenn man den operieren muss.
Irgendjemand hat schon gefragt, wann hat er zuletzt gegessen,
wann hat er zuletzt auch Berien genommen?
Ja, so ein bisschen Werte.
Wie ist die Gerinnung und was hat er für eine Blutgruppe?
Ja, genau, ja, in der Kreuzblut.
Ja, Gerinnungs-Bestellung.
Also, wie wir uns selber bestellen.
Ja, Gerinnungsparameter, Sie meinen richtig?
Gerinnungsparameter, aber auch Blutgruppe.
Aha, okay, natürlich.
Sehr gut, ja, ja, danke schön.
Gut.
Ja, dann, ähm, therapeutisch, was würde man machen?
Ähm, therapeutisch, ähm,
ja, wie habe ich schon gesagt,
intensiv stationär auf Namen und Überwachung.
Überwachung, genau.
Zugänge, Flüssigkeit, Elektrolytik,
Gaben und Konzil, chirurgisches Konzil.
Und natürlich auch, was gegen die Schmerzen, ne?
Ja, Schmerzmittel, HB-Bübelkeit, Antiemetrikum.
Mhm.
Was ist mit Spas moritikum?
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, das ist nicht krass,
das ist ein guter Problem, ne?
Ja, vielleicht auch ganz viele Zungen,
mit Spas moritikum.
Okay, gut.
Okay, dann haben wir noch, ähm,
ja, okay, ja, man würde versuchen,
ähm, die Milz zu halten.
Und, ähm, Durchschonung, ja.
Aber wenn die Verletzung zu stark ist,
was würde man dann machen?
Entfernung.
Ja, dann muss die operativ entfernt werden, ne?
Und man kann, glaube ich, trotzdem ohne Milz
mehr oder weniger problemlos weiterleben.
Ja, ja, ja, natürlich, ohne Milz ist es möglich.
Ja. Gut.
Ja, dann, ähm, halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden.
Was mit Herrn Müller ist, ist ja ein junger Mann.
Hoffen wir mal, dass er sich wieder erholt.
Und dass es dem bald besser geht.
Ja.
Also, kleine Manöverkritik, große Manöverkritik,
also das Allerwichtigste in so einem Fall,
wenn Sie Traumapartienten kriegen, ja,
jemanden mit so einer gravierenden Verletzung,
der muss sofort untersucht werden.
Da können Sie nicht weiterfragen nach...
Und Fixierung, ja.
Da müssen Sie unterbrechen und müssen sagen,
Sie müssen jetzt die Befragung unterbrechen.
Ich muss jetzt erst mal Ihre Vitalparameter überprüfen.
Okay, so jemand wird uns eine Sache geben.
Sie können weiter machen, oder wie?
Genau, das wird in der Pfüpfung so sein.
Genau.
Vielleicht geben die Ihnen noch irgendwelche Werte dazu,
dass Sie sagen, der hat jetzt ein Kult von sowieso,
der hat einen Blutdruck von sowieso,
die Laborwerte sehen so und so aus.
Kann sein, dass Sie das kriegen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das im Einzelfall ist.
Aber jedenfalls können Sie nicht weitermachen mit jemandem,
der da tot vor Ihnen liegt.
Ja, dem geht es echt schlecht.
Ja.
Und insofern darf Ihnen in der Prüfung nicht passieren.
Ja?
Dann...
Ja.
Was können wir sagen?
Jetzt muss ich das auf einem Nesegespräch unterbrechen.
Und auch brechen.
Und was tun wir? Ich muss sofort durchführen.
Ja, ich würde jetzt in diesem Fall sagen,
wir müssen das Gespräch unterbrechen.
Ich muss einige wichtige Untersuchungen im Augenblick machen.
Und dann könnte man dem Prüfer gegenüber sagen,
ich muss jetzt die Vitalparameter überprüfen
und den Patienten erst mal notfallmäßig behandeln.
Ja? Wie auch immer.
Wir können jetzt sagen, Fixierung bei Traumopatianten.
Fixierung.
Fixierung?
Ja, ohne Bewegung.
Nein, warum fixiert? Nicht Gliedmasse, Extremität.
Nur Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, vielleicht aber gibt es Rippenpraktur.
Das heißt, keine Nutzung dieser Falle.
Das kann Rippenpraktur können zum Beispiel Lungenfalle.
Aber unser Verdachtdiagnose ist meldrüptisch.
Ja, und deswegen Immobilisation.
Ist nicht notwendig.
Alles klar, okay.
Gut, so. Und dann haben wir...
Ja, das ist diese eine Geschichte.
Dann, ich glaube, das ist immer eine große Schwierigkeit,
wie ein Unfallheergang beschrieben wird.
Das habe ich schon ganz oft erlebt,
dass Kolleginnen und Kollegen da große Schwierigkeiten haben,
das nachzuvollziehen.
Fragen Sie im Zweifelsfall noch einmal nach,
damit Sie das richtig widergeben können.
Dieser Patient ist also selber auf einem Skateboard gefahren,
mit relativ hoher Geschwindigkeit
und ist dann gegen einen festen Gegenstand geprahlt,
mit der linken Körperseite, gegen einen Zaun geprahlt.
Ja, und dann hat er geschildert,
dass er sofort starke Schmerzen hatte.
Pipapo.
Also, linke Körperseite ist betroffen, das wissen wir.
Und wir wissen relativ hohe Geschwindigkeit.
Fester Gegenstand hat ihn gebremst.
Also haben wir starke mechanische Wirkung.
Gut, das muss man dann aber auch so beschreiben.
Mit der linken Körperseite gegen einen Zaun geprahlt.
Ja, so, dann weiß der Kollege, was passiert ist.
Ja, so, das ist diese Geschichte.
Dann haben Sie mit schöner Hartnäckigkeit
immer wieder Bewegungswerben mit hat ins Perfekt gesetzt.
Er hat es gekonnt. Nein, er ist gekonnt.
Immer noch.
Und Sie machen das, was alle gerne machen.
Danach, ich nehme Ihnen Blut ab.
Ja, das Verb kommt an zweite Stelle.
Danach nehme ich Ihnen Blut ab.
Ja, das ist nicht schlimm.
Es ist nicht schlimm, es machen eigentlich alle.
Und es kommt immer wieder vor.
Nur, ich weise da drauf hin, es sind die gleichen Fehler,
die immer wieder auftauchen.
Und ich sage, es ist fast jedes Mal.
Gut, Augenblick.
Ich habe eigentlich sehr oft zwischendurch interveniert,
wenn es sprachlich Probleme gab.
Und das war relativ oft.
Haben Sie gemerkt.
Ich habe sie relativ häufig unterbrochen.
Das hat natürlich dazu geführt,
dass Sie auch ein bisschen aus dem Konzept gekommen sind.
Aber wenn ich das alles aufschreibe bis zum Schluss,
ich kann das nicht alles notieren.
Es sind zu viele Sachen.
Man muss da manchmal stoppen und sagen, hallo, das heißt so und so.
Ich habe also ziemlich viel zwischendrin korrigiert.
Sie machen eben sprachlich einige Fehler.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man Ihnen das krumm nimmt in der Prüfung oder nicht.
Ich sage es Ihnen jetzt einfach.
Dass diese Fehler da sind und dass die auftauchen.
Was viel besser geworden ist,
ich konnte sie dort nicht besser verstehen,
weil sie langsamer gesprochen haben.
Und wenn sie mal wieder so schnell wurden,
habe ich gesagt, ich habe sie nicht verstanden.
Ich konnte sie wirklich nicht verstehen.
Das war keine Show.
Ich habe sie zwischendurch nicht verstanden und habe nachgefragt.
Vielen Dank.
Es ist noch ein bisschen Arbeit drin bei Ihnen.
Sie müssen noch ein bisschen sprachlich arbeiten
und sich vielleicht...
Ich weiß nicht, ob es sinnvoll ist,
sich vor Formulierungen zu machen für die Sachen.
Natürlich ist jeder Fall eine Überraschung.
Aber man kann schon gewisse Sätze vorformulieren,
dass man eben sagt,
Familien an amnestisch fand sich beim Vater
ein Kolonkarzinum vor zwei Jahren im Alter von 55.
Die Mutter leidet an Kokosartrose, Hüftep ist geplant.
Ja, so.
Das kann man ja schon vorformulieren.
Das braucht man nicht jedes Mal neu zu erfinden.
Man kann sagen, der Patient nimmt keine regelmäßige Medikation,
oder es besteht keine regelmäßige Medikation bei Bedarfs,
nimmt er aspirin oder eine Salve für seine Neurodermitis.
So.
Und genauso an Operationen schildert er
eine operative Versorgung einer Oberamffaktur links vor fünf Jahren,
die im Rahmen eines Fahrradunfalls aufgetreten ist.
Also, man kann das...
Man muss das nicht jedes Mal neu erfinden,
die Formulierung.
Man kann eigentlich schon immer die gleichen Sätze sagen.
Aber wo ich natürlich abrate,
diese Stereotypen-Listenfragen,
haben Sie Verdauungsprobleme,
haben Sie Probleme mit dem Wasserlassen,
haben Sie Schmerzen beim Atmen,
haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie.
Also, da kann man sicherlich variieren.
Aber eben diese Familienanamnese,
Sozialanamnese, da kann man ein bisschen Sätze vorformulieren,
dass man das nicht jedes Mal neu machen muss.
Wenn es schwierig ist.
Ja.
Hab ich gut gemacht oder Fehler gemacht mit dieser Frage?
Also, ich meine, bei der Familienanamnese war irgendwas
ein bisschen durcheinander.
Das kann ich mir im Einzelnen sagen.
Vielleicht müssen Sie noch mal reinhören.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe bei Ihrer Familie
irgendwelche Ertrankungen bekannt.
Nein, ich meine, das ist im Bericht, im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Aha, okay.
Also, ich glaube, die Fragen machen Sie ziemlich souverän.
Ja?
Und da gibt es, glaube ich, gar nicht viel daran zu meckern.
Sondern eben nachher im Bericht.
Und also, ich gebe zu, wahrscheinlich durch meine Nachfragen
habe ich sie zum Teil ein bisschen irritiert.
Das hat sie ein bisschen aus dem Konzept gebracht.
Nur ich habe weiße Fragen, die prüfe auch nach.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Welche Situation irritiert, ich verstehe nicht.
Ja, ich habe doch, ich habe ihr doch reingeredet.
Ja, ich habe dann zwischendurch korrigiert.
Und habe dann nachgefragt.
Und das ist sie natürlich nicht gewöhnt.
Nein, nein, das gefällt mir.
Danke schön, das gefällt mir.
Und deswegen ist sie ein bisschen aus dem Konzept gekommen.
Vielleicht, das könnte sein.
Aber irgendwo habe ich nachgefragt.
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
Also, das geht ja auch schnell.
Ich habe nicht alles auf dem Schirm.
Aber ich glaube, an irgendeiner Stelle habe ich nachgefragt,
wie lange Zeit er dazwischen hatte oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Das müsste man jetzt noch mal reinhören.
Ich habe gefragt, ob er selber gefahren ist.
Oder ob er angefahren worden ist.
Weil sie gesagt haben, er hatte einen Unfall mit einem Skateboard.
Ja? Also, das könnte ja sein,
dass er von einem kleinen Jungen, der mit dem Skateboard über die Straße gefahren ist,
angefahren wurde.
Nein, er ist selber gefahren und ist selber gegen den Zaun geknallt.
Und da hat die Oberärztin halt nachgefragt,
wie war noch mal der Unfallherger?
Ja? Und das ist aber bekanntermaßen eine große Schwierigkeit,
das zu beschreiben.
Weil es da immer wieder auf Richtung ankommt.
Und auf Bewegungswerben, die dann in der Vergangenheit mit ist,
beschrieben werden und nicht mit haben.
Ja?
Das sind halt die Probleme, die dabei auftreten.
Aber was ich eigentlich gut fand ganz am Anfang,
sind sie gleich so ziemlich zur Sache gekommen.
Sie haben gesagt, er hat sich bei uns vorgestellt,
wie näher ist gebracht worden von der Nachbarin,
weil er starke Schmerzen hat im linken Oberbau,
die aufgetreten sind nach einem Unfall.
Das hat mir gut gefallen, dass dann nicht wegen irgendwas,
was dann so ein Endlosatz war.
Ja.
Gut.
Wie gesagt, es ist ein bisschen Arbeit noch drin.